I wanna first find out how
you're doing in quarantine.
I'm finding that I'm
getting more kid time.
Is that the same with you?
Absolutely, yeah.
I mean, and it sucks, right?
No, no. It's been a..
No, no, listen to your point.
It's hard.
I'm not a fan of my family.
I don't like them and I
find them off putting.
Yeah, no exactly.
And knowing that I'm 50%
responsible for how off putting
they are is real humbling.
(Conan laughs)
I think you're, I think
you're 80% responsible.
Certainly with my daughter, you know.
I met your wife, she's lovely.
You're 80, you may be 90% responsible
for any negative qualities.
I'm louder, it's just cause I'm louder.
I take up more space, that's all.
But yeah, no we've been getting after it,
you know, it's, you know,
our kids are Otis is six,
Daisy is four and they
yeah, it's been a lot of,
well with Otis I've been taking
them through the classics.
We, you know, we've been
doing Star Wars and...
Oh, you watch the classic
movies, that's great.
Yeah, we're taking them through that.
Cause that's, I'm not a good teacher.
You know, I was never good
at even when I taught improv
at teaching level one, I was not,
I'm not Ted Lasso in that way.
He's a much better person
and teacher and leader
and coach than I am.
But you know, going
through, starting with,
you know, the Phantom
Menace and working through,
we're, you know, our next
one is Empire Strikes Back,
but it's been a super fun
way and very interesting way
to teach, and I'm sure
numerous people know this
to teach good and evil to your kids like,
and just how much they care and how much,
you know, to have your little boy,
like sit there and watch Anakin Skywalker
get more and more angry as this,
you know, this Palpatine dude is like,
you know, putting, you know,
whispering things in his ear.
And I kind of have to be,
I'm watching it with the eyes of like,
what's going on in the news today.
I'm like, oh yeah, no,
Palpatine's his son of a bitch.
He would absolutely be getting
rid of mailboxes right now.
I see what I see with this
slick, trying to pull, I get it.
I see this coming a mile away.
That's a great way to
teach your kids morality.
I did it when my kids were really little.
I made them watch Good Fellas and yeah.
And I just basically,
so that they could learn
that if the mob wants to
take over your restaurant,
don't do it cause they're gonna sell.
And it was not the good
lessons they needed to learn.
Not as clear cut as what
you're talking about.
Well, it's Goodfellas,
not good lessons, right?
I mean that's, you know, it's
right there in the title,
but we just watched ET this weekend,
we started too late on
Saturday night thinking,
oh, we'll do you know,
wait til the dark but boy,
our little guy freaked out.
He was so sad when, spaceship.
Spoilers everybody, if
you haven't seen it,
but when the spaceship takes
off and leaves ET on earth,
he freaked out in a way that was like,
I mean, I felt again, 80% responsible.
It's like, I've never done that to you.
I got immediately defensive.
Right.
It's like he like went to his bed.
It was just like, it's just so sad.
It was mostly cause he was tired.
Cause he watched it the next day.
And the whole time trying to figure out,
Daisy is hilarious, Daisy when
like Peter Coyotes character
shows up with the keys
and he's kind of ominous
and you don't know who he is.
She's just like, Oh
oh, here come the cops.
(laughter)
She knows that at what age?
She's three and a half.
Right.
She said, oh boy, here
come the cops, here we go.
Hide the weed.
(laughter)
She has all these outdated ideas.
Speaking of kids,
are your kids aware that you played
a stormtrooper in the Mandalorian?
Do they know?
Cause that would give you
the ultimate street credit?
Otis is definitely, we didn't,
we haven't watched Mandalorian.
We're not doing the
full universe, just the,
you know, the nine films.
So he hasn't watched Mandalorian yet.
But he got to come to set that day when I,
when myself and Adam Pally who I know,
you know, we got together,
we got that call,
like, I mean, yeah man, like
the six to 10 year old boy
in me was like, yes,
I'll do it, absolutely.
And then the fact that
it eventually came out
that I, that when that
thing aired and my character
as does Adams, you
know, punches baby Yoda?
Yes, I was gonna talk about this.
That hasn't come up yet.
I don't think, they don't
know that yet but...
Let's talk about this.
The entire internet
came down on top of you
because your character,
you as the stormtrooper,
you punch baby Yoda, we
have that scene right now.
Let's take a look
Waiting confirmation, knock it off.
And there you go.
There, it was.
What else, did you improvise that?
Please tell me that...
No, yeah, I wish.
(laughter)
You do when you see your baby Yoda.
No, no, no.
Exactly, it just all off
on The Great Santini style,
knowing like the craziest
thing about that is,
you know, I did this thing
months earlier and it was,
you know, one afternoon,
you know, again, truly dream come true,
dressing up like that, doing
it, oh, just coming down
and then went away and then
did a hundred and other things,
you know, writing the Ted Lasso show,
shooting the Ted Lasso, all this stuff,
you know, life goes on.
And then they rolled those episodes out,
you know, one at a time and
Otis and I were sitting in here,
you know, playing video
games or something.
I forget on a Saturday or Sunday morning.
And Olivia comes in with
her phone and she goes,
hey, you're trending on Twitter.
And I was like, oh, how about that?
And I don't, I'm not on Twitter,
like actively in that way.
And so immediately it was like, wait, why?
You know, in today's age,
it's like, wait, am I dead?
Did I die?
Am I cancelled?
What happened?
And it was that I was being
cancelled in real time
that it was like, you hit baby Yoda?
And I had like that moment,
like the end of sixth sense or red tattoo,
you know I'm just like, oh right.
I should have been able to anticipate two
and a half months earlier when baby Yoda
became like the belle of the ball,
you know, on the internet and everything,
everybody talking about it
didn't even it didn't even,
I totally forgot that.
Oh yeah, I backhand this little...
You haul off and you
really wail on baby Yoda
and it's, that's a career,
I think that's a career killer, I'm sorry.
You would think, you would think,
but because you couldn't
see my face because people,
you know, I can always say that it was,
you know, that they manipulated that.
I didn't know they were going to do that.
CGI.
I've had some.
CGI, your arm.
(Jude laughs)
That's exactly, it's like, I'll be damned.
How did that happen?
Yeah, so I'm still dealing with it.
I, but I, but you know,
I know what Jim Gavin has gone through.
I get it, I get it.